[Música]
seis días atrás el mundo presenció una
violenta erupción volcánica bajo el mar
en la zona del archipiélago de tonga el
tsunami que le siguió dejó al país
insular incomunicado durante varios días
y hoy los ciudadanos continúan luchando
por limpiar la ceniza volcánica para
permitir el acceso de la ayuda
extranjera y también liberar las fuentes
hídricas y de alimentos contaminados el
centro de vuelo espacial goddard de la
nasa dijo que la fuerza de la opción del
sábado pasado se estimó equivalente
entre 5 y 10 megatones de tnt o más de
500 veces la bomba nuclear que eeuu
lanzó sobre la ciudad japonesa de
hiroshima esto al final de la guerra
mundial muchos se han preguntado cómo
sucedió y por qué la explosión fue tan
grande como el tsunami que viajó tan
lejos qué pasará después de esto y que
otras preguntas les puede responder con
nuestro invitado del día por eso quiere
saludar en este momento a gino gonzález
vulcanólogo de la organización volcanes
sin fronteras máster en manejo de
desastres en énfasis en volcanes y
también terremotos estudiante de
doctorado de vulcanología de la
universidad bar ya en italia mejor dicho
estamos con el que es gracias por estar
con nosotros aquí en directo américa de
france 24 hoy y no le pregunto porque la
erupción entonces volcánica de tonga fue
tan violenta y que podemos esperar en un
futuro
bueno la es la erupción del volcán a
tonga happy es una erupción como se lo
dice bastante violenta porque tenemos
aquí dos elementos claves uno un
vulcanismo explosivo vulcanismo como tal
de esta isla y además es un volcán esta
es prácticamente parte de él bajo el
nivel del mar de hecho la isla ante
tracción tenía una decena de metros
sobre el nivel del mar pero el voltaje
total tiene pues una altura desde la
base desde el fondo marino
hasta que llega a la superficie sobre el
nivel del mar estamos hablando de 12 mil
metros que es lo que pasa acá que sea
una extensión de algo que nosotros
llamamos creator magmática esto
significa en palabras muy simples como
cuando nosotros tenemos el sartén con el
aceite caliente y donde vamos a hacer no
sé los huevos a la mañana de 2 vitesse
nosotros llegamos a ese aceite está
bastante caliente agregamos unas gotitas
de agua y eso va a generar o explosión
violenta
y algo así fue lo que sucedió en esta
explosión de ese volcán de las islas de
tonga el magma interactuar con el agua y
en unas cantidades precisas para generar
una expresión tan violenta como la que
experimentamos el pasado sábado ahora
allí no le quiero preguntar cuál es la
diferencia de estos volcanes submarinos
de los que normalmente conocemos los que
están afuera del agua le pregunto si
entonces estos submarinos son
potencialmente más peligrosos y que
pueden causar más daños
bueno aquí tenemos
la diferencia básicamente tienes volta
en este específico de tomb de la isla de
tonga y de las islas de tonga lo tenemos
dos compuestos básicos ahora es el magma
el agua y el espesor de la capa de agua
es relativamente pequeño o no es tan
profundo porque si es muy profundo no
tendríamos una explosión tan violenta
porque la presión hidrostática sería muy
alta en este caso se combinaron dos
cosas ideales para que se viera algo tan
tan explosivo y violento en otros
volcanes por ejemplo los volcanes que
están en américa en américa del sur o en
centroamérica son volcanes suba aéreos
es decir que están sobre la superficie
pero también son muy muy violentos que
hemos tenido erupciones muy muy grandes
en chile también en ecuador en colombia
este implicar a guatemala es un poco
diferente en wii está mismo porque el
agua y ahí viene pues básicamente del
magma
en este caso teníamos un extra que es el
mar
y esto fuera aún más violento y además
podríamos agregarle otras cosas que
están bajo la destrucción de los
científicos que es también el posible
colapso de parte del edificio volcánico
y entonces esto estos dos elementos
generarán el ciudadano impacta a costas
a más de diez mil kilómetros de
distancia
ahora se puede en un futuro evitar estas
situaciones como la que vimos en tonga
allí nuestros fenómenos son
completamente impredecibles
bueno aquí es algo que es básico el
volcán hace su trabajo es hacer erupción
el volcán va a seguir haciendo erupción
vamos a seguir teniendo terremotos y es
que además estas islas se encuentran en
un lugar muy particular hay que tener
muy claro que son del cinturón de fuego
del pacífico donde están los terremotos
más grandes y las elecciones más
violentas del planeta entonces ahí
tenemos ya esas condiciones ahora
prevenir un desastre como haces es muy
difícil conforme pasa el tiempo porque a
pesar de que nosotros como científicos
la ciencia va avanzando muy rápidamente
y el monitoreo de los volcanes tenemos
la variable del cambio climático que en
el caso de los terremotos sino voltajes
podríamos digamos de pensar de que no
tenemos una afectación el efecto que
estamos haciendo nosotros por el cambio
climático pero en el caso de las islas
polinesias y en el caso específico de
esta ciudad de tumba con el cambio
climático el nivel del mar sigue en
aumento y esas islas son muy expuestas a
estas variaciones entonces cuando ocurre
el próximo terremoto o la próxima gran
erupción
el impacto de eso es una mitad es va a
ser más y más grande en estas ideas
entonces lo que nosotros estamos
haciendo a miles de kilómetros de
distancia a quien más afecta son estas
siglas y ya de por sí son muy
vulnerables lleno en américa latina'
cuáles son los volcanes que las
autoridades deberían tenerle el ojo a lo
mejor volcanes que posiblemente puedan
tener una nueva erupción y que no ocurra
lo que ocurre en tonga ya sabemos que
algo un poco impredecible pero pues algo
se debería saber no un volcán que a lo
mejor estuvo en una actividad y no sé si
los volcanes tienen un periodo como de
explotar de activarse nuevamente lleno
bueno los volcanes si nosotros estamos
estudiando bien así como usted lo
comenta necesitamos pues
por así decirlo el volcán siempre va a
señales pero tenemos que estar ahí en el
entonces se necesita inversión en este
tema en inversión mismo imperio
volcánico y además conocer el pasado y
esto es fundamental
eso es como por ejemplo si usted llegan
de un médico no y se llega con todos los
síntomas
debajo es prácticamente darle un paro
cardiaco no primero usted tiene que
saber su historial médico previo para
saber qué posible potencial va a tener
de una determinada enfermedad o algo así
es con las cifras de comprar algo si
deberíamos de saberlo en todos los
volcanes del del mundo en este caso que
nos interesa más a nosotros de
latinoamérica saber la historia
deductiva de cada vuelta para conocer su
potencial ahora bien los volcanes
especialmente en centroamérica y parte
de sudamérica las personas viven muy
cerca de mis otras grandes ciudades
viven sobre los volcanes y esto hace que
sea un sitio de mayor riesgo entonces el
volcán va a hacer su trabajo
en algún momento va a ser elección si
los monitoreamos y podemos saber conocer
las pistas antes de una erupción pero
ahora viene la otra parte que es
preparar a la población entonces es un
trabajo en conjunto que va desde las
comunidades que generalmente es viven
las más pobres viven cerca de los
volcanes entonces es un trabajo lento y
si empezamos a trabajar en educación de
los niños de las comunidades para cuando
ocurra esa adicción que va a ocurrir en
algún momento el terremoto están listos
para evacuar o por ejemplo para que no
nos esté pasando esta contaminación de
las fuentes de agua que está sucediendo
en tonga proteger las fuentes de agua
desde ya entonces es una especie de
entrenamiento para que cuando ocurra la
reacción estar listos llenos ya muy
rápidamente hay científicos que también
dicen que el suelo se va a fertilizar
más con esta ceniza volcánica eso eso es
cierto
bueno afortunadamente y nosotros vimos
en latinoamérica el café colombia todo
centroamérica es gracias a los las
erupciones volcánicas en algún momento
el suelo va a tener la capacidad de
absorber estos minerales que son
expulsados por por esta violenta
erupción y con el tiempo va a hacerte el
turno algunas veces decimos que en la
erupción verdad está resignando el
impacto pero en el futuro va a ser un
beneficio